about the power of art in political
movements a single image
or piece of art can come to embody an
entire movement we saw it in vietnam we
saw it in the civil rights movement
now a new wave of political art is
emerging across the country
and we spoke to some of the remarkable
artists in the new social justice
movement
when protests erupted after trayvon
martin an unarmed florida teenager
was shot and killed in 2012 nicholas
smith had to process it all
through his art the art is therapy for
me
trayvon martin had been wearing a hoodie
when he died
and i created this piece of martin
luther king jr in a hoodie
the portrait caught fire across the
internet
when that piece of martin luther king in
a hoodie
started going viral yeah what was your
first reaction
i was kind of in shock that's when i
realized
like this is a social experiment if you
look at dr king in a hoodie
and say you feel threatened all of a
sudden you say that he looks like a thug
then
that was the point to show that it's
really not about
our outward appearance
[Music]
this past may after the death of george
floyd at the hands of police
black lives matter commissioned smith to
paint floyd's portrait
there's a particular look on george
floyd's face in that painting
yeah how would you describe it i feel
like his face
is just questioning it's saying
how could this have happened you left
the painting kind of unfinished
yeah his life was unfinished when a
black lives matter street mural
was organized in charlotte north
carolina georgie nakima
knew she had to take part it's something
where i kind of dropped everything that
i was doing because i realized how
important this was
nakima's colorful murals appear all over
charlotte
my aim is to embrace this cultural
diversity
and give it some visual representation
and i'm trying to like
recreate the narrative and tell one that
is more uplifting
and just conveys resilience on the black
lives matter collaboration
she was assigned a letter you painted
the m
yes i painted the n it's a great looking
m oh i do what i can thank you
when you stood back and looked at the
final project
what did you see i think i saw a lot of
hope and i think i saw a big shift in
the culture
because it was not just black people
out there so it was just a very humbling
experience
this is the motto this is the motto
history is happening now
is the motto for a new outdoor exhibit
at the museum of the city of new york
called new york responds chief curator
sarah henry has the daunting task of
preserving history
as we're living it the role of the
artist and the visual image has been
important for
decades and decades because art is
visual it's emotional and it's impactful
and it's immediate and it's immediate to
capture the moment
the museum's curators have been
collecting images
of both the pandemic and the protests
shared
on instagram it's amazing the power
a single image can have yes
so many movements in us history have
taken on a life
in a single image they are just seared
in our memories
george floyd's face as captured by
artists
is one of those it can grab people so
fast
if i can grab people's attention i want
to grab it and show them how we can move
forward
after the response to his martin luther
king jr
in a hoodie portrait nicholas smith
launched his
sunday sketch series on social media
every sunday i started creating
pieces that reflect what's going on in
the world kind of based off of nina
simone's quote of you know
it's an artist's duty to reflect the
times smith had spent 11 years
designing theme parks for disney
imagineering
but last summer he quit to pursue his
passion
he's made hollywood movie posters and
illustrated children's books
but the tragedies keep coming in some
ways it must be very difficult for you
to do all of these
yeah especially especially elijah mclean
it took some days to process
it
and then at some point like the grief
and the anger
takes over every time it's just like it
gets to a boiling point where i'm like
i have to process this through my art
like i have to
it's a bit of a paradox because as much
inspiration as
you're getting to make this kind of art
in many ways
you wish you didn't have it right
absolutely my goal is that i
didn't have a job i don't want to have
any more hashtags
any more people to have to commemorate
these people should still be here
[Music]
you may have seen smith's most recent
viral work two very notable portraits
the first is chadwick boseman as the
king of wakanda visiting a child with
cancer
the second maybe even more meaningful to
nicholas
it's a portrait of his babies zion who
arrived in july just after we
interviewed him weighing
five pounds and six ounces he already
has his own portrait so our
congratulations to nicholas and his
lovely wife vanessa who i also talked to
um
they're very proud parents at this point
but it's as you see it's it's
this isn't proved to be an incredibly
inspirational time not in
necessarily in the most positive way but
it's a these artists are very important
to what's going on i like what she said
art is visual
emotional and immediate yes i love what
you said to nikima when she said when
you said
it's a very good-looking m i thought
well how what what
how good-looking could it be anthony and
then you showed it and you went well
nakima
that is a very good-looking image she
goes yeah i just sort of do what i can
and nicholas
good lord i like recovering as your
piece does so well that history is
happening right now
we're living through it it adds an edge
to everything that we see each day
and you make a wonderful point there is
so much material right now so much
inspiration but so much of it you don't
want no
no when did you see anthony that made
you think uh there's a story here i want
to do something well
you know my stepfather was a as a
painter an artist so i'm very affected
by visual things and i was really
stunned by some of the images that came
out
particularly out of george floyd's death
there were some really striking
portraits that that were very moving and
i just thought you know
here it's happening again i remember as
a kid growing up during the vietnam war
there were some there were some very
powerful images
that came to symbolize everything you
see that and you had an immediate
reaction
and then you thought let me find out
who's doing it yeah and then that's what
we did we
we went looking for the people uh who
who were making the the images that were
being spread everywhere and nicholas
smith
as you said where is he is he i believe
he's in california wow